que se passe-t-il en ce moment même
registre le sommet dans la vallée du
plan de chair est ce que les talibans
ont repris le contrôle dans la zone high
encore une incertitude sur cette
victoire des romans on peut comprendre
que d'après le communiqué officiel des
talibans ils sont maîtres de
l'afghanistan c'est ce qu'ils ont dit
ils ont conquis la vallée du panjshir et
un certain nombre de deux tirs a été
entendue dans l'est dans la capitale
kaboul à kandahar et dans les
principales villes à cette annonce que
les talibans étaient m officiellement 2
de l'ensemble du territoire afghan il
reste quand même un certain doute sur la
persistance de poches de résistance dans
le panchir c'est que pour le jir
traditionnellement est une région
tellement escarpé dont le les sommets la
plupart des sommets comme une commune
culmine pardon à plus de 5000 mètres que
c'est un endroit sur lesquels les russes
pendant l'occupation de l'afghanistan
s'était cassé les dents à quatre
reprises et les talibans de la
précédente du précédent gouvernement
taliban entre 96 et 2001 n'était jamais
parvenu à conquérir le refuge du fameux
commandant massoud là c'est son fils qui
est à la manoeuvre avec comment
également l'ancien vice président saleh
de l'afghanistan iranienne un pôle de
résistance qui s'est fait les les
combattants promis de lutter jusqu'à la
dernière goutte de leur sang pour cette
vallée du panjshir là il semble que
malheureusement on soit dans les
dernières heures de lutte
en tout cas on peut espérer en tout cas
que la plupart des leaders de la
résistance afghane qui sont là puissent
évacué en hélicoptère ça c'est une
option qui l'est qui leur reste pour
pouvoir éventuellement se replier le
fils du commandant massoud qui a démenti
sur twitter la prise de la vallée du
panjshir par des talibans il évoque des
informations est ce qu on assiste aussi
à une bataille de communication entre
les deux camps bataille de communication
évidente depuis le début de la semaine
l'offensive a commencé on a d'abord ce
sont les laits comment les résistants
aux talibans donc le mouvement donc de
la lnr qui a communiqué en disant qu'ils
avaient tué 200 300 talibans dedans
déchiffrable absolument effrayant en
disant qu'est talibans n'avaient pas
réussi que leurs enfants s'ils avaient
échoué et puis on s'est quand même rap
est reçue et tous les renseignements
qu'on a pu avoir au fil de la journée
montrer quand même que les talibans
avaient réussi persée qu'un certain
nombre de combattants de la résistance
afghane également et avaient été tués
dans l'offensive donc ça a été
probablement très meurtrier encore une
fois vale est extrêmement escarpé
territoire afghan par excellence
incontrôlable qui est le le le commander
un petit peu le symbole de cette
afghanistan incontrôlable mais des zones
entières comme ça qu'ils peuvent
échapper au pouvoir central si les
talibans arrivent dès maintenant à
asseoir leur autorité sur l'afghanistan
c'est une nouveauté parce que je vous
répète la vallée du plan de jeu on
n'avait jamais été conquise on attend
l'annoncé du nouveau d'un gouvernement
taliban dans les prochaines heures
peut-être
demain est ce que les talibans peuvent
inclure dans leurs gouvernements qu'ils
disent vouloir inclusif est ce qu ils
peuvent inclure des opposants tels que
ceux qu'ils affrontent en ce moment même
dans la vallée du point de chair est ce
qu'on peut imaginer le fils du
commandant massoud
ministre oui je pense que c'est peu
probable en revanche par rapport à leurs
anciens opposants est ce qu'on appelait
les hommes de l'alliance du nord
notamment les ouzbeks l'état les
talibans ont déjà admis que luz b la
langue bousbecque tu resterais comme une
des langues officielles de l'afghanistan
ce qui est totalement nouveau par
rapport à ce que les pratiques qu'ils
ont eu pendant et après leur précédente
administration
donc il ya une volonté ils ont montré
une volonté d'être inclusif à dai kundi
par exemple qui est une un petit état
dans la za rajab est de rendre la zone
du centre d'aghanistan contrôlée par
l'ethnie hazara qui n'êtes ni
traditionnellement hostile aux talibans
ils ont renommé un gouverneur de
l'ethnie hazara paraît impensable avant
donc ils ont fait des efforts de pour
tendre la main pour le moment
théoriquement et puis ce qui va être
intéressant dans ce gouvernement c'est
de savoir quelles vont être la place de
tel ou tel on sait qu'il y a donc le
fils du mollah omar qui est là qu il y
ait qui peut postuler à un poste de
ministre et puis à cette personnalité
est très intéressant qui est le mollah
baradar qui a été qui est bleu
officiellement donc il ya le chef
spirituel des talibans à kunda qui lui
ne siégera pas au gouvernement qui est
une force spirituelle qui quand même
assez inquiétante humble ce profil du
chef des talibans c'était le chef de
l'administration de la justice donc de
la charia à l'époque des talibans donc
avant 2001 le mollah baradar est un peu
différent lui il a connu le mollah omar
baradar c'est-à-dire brothers donc
c'était
mollah omar qui lui avait donné ce nom
donc on est dans du taliban quand même
qui puise sa légitimité dans l'ancien
gouvernement taliban et puis quand même
c'est quelqu'un qui a négocié avec les
américains qui a négocié avec khalid zad
c'est quelqu'un qui était qui a fait des
études aussi avec hamid karzaï donc
c'est quand même quelqu'un qui a une
certaine connaissance du monde ce n'est
pas simplement un taliban obscures qui
vient de kandahar où de l'allemande
c'est quelqu'un de 2 voilà deux qui est
tourné vers le monde donc si c'est lui
qui forment le gouvernement afghan il ya
quand même une chance pour que ce
gouvernement taliban montre des signes
entre guillemets de modération des
d'inclusion et surtout d'un souhait
parce que ça c'est important et c'est
crucial c'est bien de faire d'être
conquérant héroïque dans les campagnes
et de montrer sa kalachnikov et ses
beaux habits quand il faut arriver dans
les villes et gérer l'économie d'un pays
c'est autre chose les finances etc etc
tout ça ça va être la tâche du nouveau
gouvernement taliban ils ont bien
l'intention d'y réussir ils ont
probablement pas l'intention de laisser
seul essai non plus débordés par des
groupes extrémistes terroristes etc qui
peuvent servir éventuellement reprendre
l'afghanistan comme un sanctuaire ça va
être la clé des premiers mois du nouveau
gouvernement taliban et on verra ce que
ça donnera si les combattants anti
taliban de la vallée du panjshir ne
participe pas au futur gouvernement
taliban qu'est ce qu'il adviendra d'eux
ces prochains mois qu'est ce qu'il
représente aujourd'hui en terme de
forces vives en termes de poids
politique aussi est-ce qu'ils ont le
soutien de la population alors non
clairement c'est essentiellement des
combattants tadjik qui sont donc
l'ethnie du commandant massoud et de sa
famille et de son clan le pen jr est une
vallée très étriqué elle et elle ne
ressemble pas au reste de l'afghanistan
qui lui-même un ensemble de vallées en
tout cas pour toute la partie nord donc
souvent qu'ils n'ont aucune aucun
contact les unes avec les autres donc
ils s'imaginaient que la résistance du
pandjchir même si elle tient puisse
débordé reconquérir l'afghanistan je
pense que c'est totalement illusoire
ensuite il peut y avoir une résistance
intéressante qu'on la voit d'ailleurs
porté par des femmes alors elles ne sont
pas très nombreuses mais elles
manifestent elles ont manifesté à kaboul
les ont manifesté aussi à djalalabad
une zone pachtoune très proche de la
frontière pakistanaise une grande ville
mais c'est pas une ville d'éclairer
c'est une ville plutôt traditionnelle et
donc on a vu des femmes se levait faire
des manifestations dans la rue pour
demander les droits des femmes les
talibans n'ont pas ne sont pas
intervenus pour les chats c'est donc
qu'il peut y avoir aussi lé peut-être
une forme de résistance à ce niveau là
il faut pas oublier que l'afghanistan
d'aujourd'hui n'est pas l'afghanistan
dix à vingt ans riel 20 ans d'occupation
américaines que pendant ces vingt ans
des villes les villes principalement se
sont tournés vers le monde elles ont
subi des influences occidentales que
beaucoup d'afghans ont communié avec le
monde ça va être difficile pour les
talibans de supprimer les réseaux
sociaux d'autant plus que moi j'ai pu
constater avec eux ils les utilisent
beaucoup eux aussi donc les talibans eux
aussi ont changé moi j'écrivais je sais
que j'avais rencontré donc dans dans la
province du wardak un certain nombre de
combattants par les anglais parce qu'il
avait appris l'anglais à l'université de
kaboul c'est impensable qu'un cliché les
talibans quand elle qu'ils ont déferlé
en 96 sur kaboul l'exécutant les gens
comme on rafalant des femmes à la
mitrailleuse dans les stades et l'api
dans les couples adultères y'a que
talibans qui détaille banques sont
rentrés dans le câble ou le sont pas
forcément plus gentil en tout cas ils
n'ont pas fait oeuvre pour le moment de
sauvagerie public il ya certainement eu
des règlements de compte ça on n'est pas
naïf parce qu'ils avaient leur ennemi
des membres du gouvernement des membres
des unités d'élite qui l'auront fait la
guerre pendant très longtemps et avec
lesquels il n'y a pas de compromis
possible une partie son compte évacuer
avec les américains mais une partie sont
restés je pense que là ça lui est
effectivement il ya eu des règlements de
comptes mais en tout cas ces règlements
de comptes n'ont pas été public moi j'ai
su aussi par un renseignement
afghans très bas fakih qui connaît très
bien les talibans que ils ont pris des
gouverneurs militaires cinq gouverneurs
militaires pour kaboul qui font partie
des gens de parwan des gens d'aidé en
fait d'aider commandés
des états qui sont juste autour de
kaboul et qu'ils sont entre guillemets d
éduquer ils ont refusé que des gens de
kandahar où de l'allemande ou même de
nangarhar qu est la province la plus à
l'est vienne dirigé kaboul pour donner
justement peut-être que pour contrôler
les clés combattants et faire que ceux
ci ne se livrent pas des exactions dans
tout ça a été extrêmement étudié au sein
de la hiérarchie talibane pour que lier
cet aspect c'est cette image que veulent
donner les talibans aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup pour votre regard est
juste sublime grand reporter cherté
france